don't we've known you for I think what
ten years okay long time and I know you
you've come up with some great analogies
which I would love to go into later I
know you talk about the red carpet
producer which I still love that that
term anyway but one thing I want to ask
you about is I heard you see it
somewhere else you said being in
Hollywood and staying here for a length
of time will not maybe change you but
it'll just make you more of what you
already are mm yeah okay well that was
the advice that was given to me many
years ago before I moved out here by a
person who had worked in Hollywood with
Jerry Bruckheimer and he said John you
you want to take a really good stock of
yourself here now because everything
that you do here everything that you
think everything that you believe
everything that you indulge in go to our
bad it will be available to you out here
at a much greater level and degree and
things that you don't even know about
wool are abundant you said you will
become more of who you are rather than
it changing you you'll actually be able
to fulfill all of those things that are
both inside of you and how you feel and
the way you see the world and the kind
of friends that you hang out with and
the things that you go and do in your
spare time and so I took that to heart I
didn't understand it other than the you
know observable okay he's telling me to
think about myself and think about Who I
am deeply I wasn't worried in that
regard but in my 18 years out here I
would say that that statement is still
very true today not just for myself but
for any of us I think it's it's
Hollywood affords you a lot of things
not just the film industry but Los
Angeles its abundant its abundant
everywhere you want to go there are
several Starbucks within walking
distance there are multiple places and
things that you can do and there's also
a variety of people that may be in your
small town there were only one or two
there are now dozens if not hundreds and
a lot of them have money so you know
taking that into perspective and and
looking at these last several years
growth it can challenge you to and the
only answer that I have for that is
really to look deeper within yourself
and some of those things that you have
to look deeper within can be painful
they can cause you to feel disappointed
about when you don't get what you want
when you create something that is not
received well when you when you don't
win the approval of certain people that
you maybe want to work with or have
access to or get to quote the next level
but fundamentally I think what it
teaches you that discipline of
introspection is one where you become
more fulfilled and happy because of what
you are actually doing that is true to
yourself as opposed to trying to worry
about what others outside expect of you
you have to start with your own internal
expectations and those things may evolve
but they they can only evolve because of
you not because of someone else giving
you an opportunity or not or someone
else approving of you or not ultimately
at the end of day how you feel about
yourself is is a person that's up in
here and what's in here and that
personal commitment was the one that I
found in my journey to go through
Hollywood which was who is really Who am
I Who am I truly inside and what do I
really believe about this world looking
at things with new eyes being critical
of myself not to the point where you put
yourself down
I think that's an external issue but
really one where you go okay what do I
want to do with my life what are the
things that I believe about this world
do I believe in the bad things about
world do I also believe in the beauty of
the world and what holds it all together
and how am I gonna grow up and how do I
affect through art what I see and know
to be true and give something to that
that inspires how I feel in me to others
and so it comes from a personal place
where we all have journeys as artists
we're sensitive we're very open people
but there is a I guess you could say if
you're gonna use that sensitivity to
tell stories or say things do it
truthfully do it through the vehicle of
art and your personal commitment is one
that is an evolution in yourself so what
I knew 10 years ago and what I know
today is very different but that doesn't
mean that what I knew 10 years ago was
wrong it's just all I was able to do at
the time what I was capable of and so
drawing from those experiences those
hardships even the times where you feel
really down you know maybe even
depressed in some cases is not always at
the time that you see that as a real
opportunity but it is in those moments
that you're challenged the most that
shows you not only what you're capable
of but what you're also really good at
because you don't have everything going
for you the way you expected it to or
hope to or wanted it to and so you have
to dig deeper but if you're deep you're
digging deep is to blame or attack or
get frustrated and say you know these
people over here causing me to you know
what they don't know you I mean they can
do whatever they want to do but it's
about yourself and the journey through
that process of becoming your truest
self is the one that gives you the
greatest success at least I believe that
because looking back between where I
started on one our fantasy girl to now a
child's voice and six movies later in
ten years
I am so grateful for that process
because it had its ups and downs and the
only way that I can measure it is that
I'm happier than I ever have been in my
entire life and I want to keep getting
happier and I want to keep doing stories
that are not talked about I want to do
things that help inspire the good in
people because it inspires the good in
me
so the truest part of those statements
about people who are you know that it
doesn't change you it's really that you
do fulfill more of who you are if you
allow yourself to commit to that rather
than trying to chase after things and
make it so that you know somebody in
Hollywood will quote pay attention to
your work but really go out there for
the reason that you want to you want to
touch audiences you want to touch people
I also said some years ago I didn't
really understand at the time and I
think it was more because of the digital
world that we were emerging in 10 years
ago after the financial crash and how
everything was going digital and online
obviously it's played itself out quite
well it's still evolving but I said
something that Hollywood is not the
audience it never has been and I would
say that irregardless of what Hollywood
does as an industry in its executives
and and all of those things I think
there are really great people working in
there I have no doubt that there are
people that really want to make a
difference and do good things in their
work but at the same time chasing after
those those agendas and and modeling
yourself after them I think really in
art you can become bold and unique and
different and stand out and the only way
I see people doing that is by commitment
full commitment to the belief and what
they're doing such the point that it's
not an issue for them about who's
getting involved in not their
to make the film at whatever level they
have to do it with the capacity and the
capabilities that they're they're not
waiting out for somebody else to come in
there and and you know just say it's
okay we got you everything's fine now
it's really more so what's up in here
and in here and trying to create that
vision and align people who feel the
same way you do our joining you on this
journey and going through it because
there's a commitment from within them
and I think as a producer there is a
responsibility there to set that kind of
tone which is not an authoritarian one
it's one of of your ownself and
attracting those kinds of people and
that's how we've been able to do the
movies that we've done because we didn't
have big funders we we did crowd-sourced
we did our own personal funds we brought
other people into the mix that were kind
of like silent investors they just
wanted us to do well and I can't wait
for what we do next
I really can't when that person said to
you about you know Hollywood only kind
of make you more of what you already are
um what did you think at that moment
this was how long ago 10 years no 18 18
18 19 years ago Wow
I got a little scared at first cuz I
didn't know like well what what is he
seen you know in me and I knew that I
had certain you know family issues when
I grew up
it's kind of what got me into art I
could say the creative role but I think
also he was genuinely concerned because
he saw a decent person who had an
idealistic view and there's nothing
wrong with that
but at the same time it's I think when
you're younger it's just a position not
of stupidity or foolishness but maybe
just ignorance because you don't have
that experience yet to know when you're
tempted with you know something that you
you if you had your parent there it
certainly wouldn't be happening you know
you wouldn't be contemplating well maybe
I should but in the moment you don't
realize that in when you're open and
you're sensitive some of that can come
from trauma and you don't realize that
your reality as you see it in front of
you is actually a reflection of that so
every choice that you make seems
reasonable but it may be coming from a
place of fear it may be coming from a
place of reaction where you had to do
something I mean I this is some of the
stuff I've learned but where people who
are criminals I'm just taking this as an
extreme we see high speed car chases all
the time right we all know how that ends
every time for the last 20 years we've
been seeing how the car chase ends when
the cops are following you you don't get
away but yet time and time again people
continue to do that reason being and
what I've learned in my research in my
own discovery not that I'm a criminal
but but that a lot of what we do that is
that is irrational to the outside is in
fact rational to us because it's a it's
a positive behavior that warded off
something else earlier in life and it's
been imprinted in us that this is what
gives us a positive outcome totally
unconscious of it totally about a set of
certain you know like choices you wake
up every morning you have certain
choices and this person over here has a
different set of choices given their
environment their background the way
they think about things so when he said
that to me I I didn't understand the
depth of it but coming full circle now I
would give that same advice to any young
person who's coming out to LA not as a
cost
about them but to be mindful of yourself
and watch how you respond how you think
how you act according to what is
presented in front of you and that takes
unfortunately sometimes it takes
experience of some very difficult
decisions that you make at the time that
seemed right or maybe you know not not
so bad but then as it played out you
realized wow I I really did screw up
there or I made a bad choice and I went
against my gut instinct I think that's
the best I will say this anybody who's
listening that this your gut instinct is
probably your best choice the first
thing that you think about in in
reaction without knowing any information
is probably the most honest of anything
as opposed to trying to logically talk
your way through it
you know I've had situations where I
wanted certain people to be a part of
our projects and didn't realize that
they didn't want to be a part of our
project they needed a paycheck fine you
know that's their right but because I
felt that I needed them I limited my
choices to that individual and attached
myself to the idea that I had to make
that work as opposed to opening up and
looking at all the other possibilities
that are out there now that sounds very
rational and logical but at the time it
was personal it was emotional that I was
attached to having needing to have that
person in order to validate what I was
doing and win to get it that's my own
personal issue but if I'm not exploring
that and looking at the consequences of
that thinking and that behavior and the
outcomes that it gives me then I only
have one of two choices I'm going to be
completely stubborn and I'm gonna be I'm
going to force it or all of that time
energy and effort that I'm using I can
use
to look open and outward and look at
other people who may be able to to give
me those things that I want that I truly
want to find and find the best match and
experience has taught me that that's a
very good thing to do so well it's not
just all so - I think falling prey to
temptation I know they say sometimes
like recovery meetings are held in Vegas
to test your song the test your sobriety
and every trigger you have a V Las Vegas
but but flattery and that's something
that as a young person you know you walk
down the street and you get someone
stopping their car and saying you would
be perfect for this and especially - if
you're coming with a set of let's get
really therapist e tools that aren't you
know maybe the best that is gonna be
like you're gonna hear angels mm-hmm and
so if you see that enough then you you
would be prey to other things as well
and so I think flattery and it can
happen later on it can happen and you
don't realize that sometimes you'll
never hear from that person again and
that that is the thing that you kind of
have to guard yourself up yeah that's
that's an experience that I found like
I've had people sit down with me Full
Tilt with meetings having watched our
previous films having read the script
and offering a ton of things and I like
this sounds great and then nothing and
I'm gonna woman introduce you to this
person that person you know I I don't
know what that person's motivations were
or or not but to spend my time getting
upset about it or or obsessing over it
or trying to figure out that person's
problem and then look at you know I
guess it only hurts me in the end but
I've I've encountered that before where
you know you can be very you know early
on in my career out here as an actor in
fact
[Music]
it's uh you know you know going out on a
business meeting and having things not
you know and when we're talking about an
era of me - it happens to guys - has
never been talked about but there are
you know there are people in Hollywood -
you know they have a right to do what
they want but when they cross the line
of kind of putting you in a position
where you know you're not you're not
able to conduct you know yourself as a
person and have to kind of adjust
according to them it's now you're kind
of you're selling yourself into
something that is really not about you
anymore it's about what you do for that
person and and it is easy you you know
compliments are very easy to give but at
the same time you have to have your own
Center your own self-worth so that you
know that if you're if you're dealing in
business and you want you know you are
talented and you believe your talent or
you have something to offer find
somebody who's looking for that in you
like you know the look and everything I
mean I I do cast all of our films and I
have seen random people that I've gone
up to and I said you know you have a
really great presence just just and I
said you know I'd really like to see
what you look like on camera and I mean
that in truthfully because I love
discoveries of talent this is how we've
been able to make all of our movies with
these talented people who are not Union
most of them are not and and not because
I'm against the Union but it just has to
do with cost and everything else that
we're trying to do and we pay everybody
but but it has more to do with you know
like being authentic and being genuine
and and being professional and I think
you can be all of those things and still
get the desired result that you want
without having to do all this other kind
of stuff which is more of like I'm gonna
make you feel good so I can get
something from you which is all they
have to offer use the truth according to
what I see and that could be totally
wrong and you tell me hey goes you know
it's like you get lost but that's your
right all I'm doing is making it an
attempt to try to say hey
I see something here I think there's
something really good here and I'd like
to I'd like to see if it's gonna work
for what I want to do when you think
back to producing one our fantasy girl
which forgive me that was your first
producing credit okay
- now you've six and then you have two
more or more in the pipeline right okay
what how was your vision of being a
producer changed so the first one you
know you had this one set of ideals and
beliefs and now all the way to to this
these upcoming projects so I think when
I when I got into Hollywood and as a
producer I had been working for three
years to get one project off the ground
that fell apart within a weekend oh wow
that was yeah that was and that happened
in 2007 so Edgar and I had been working
for Edgar Bravo the writer director it
was my business partner at no
restrictions he and I had been working
for years to try to get these projects
off the ground they were like two or
three of them and we had gotten very far
we were talking about like you know
getting into CAA getting into the studio
system getting meetings with people that
could make things happen like very
quickly if they got behind you and so we
had amassed a good momentum and we had
put a large portion of the financing
together so when we did when our fantasy
girl I was not happy to be quite honest
I wasn't happy because we were starting
from a budget on another project of 2.5
million and now we were going to tens of
thousands of dollars and you know it's a
huge drop-off there and and so
emotionally it's it's very difficult
because you want to be where you had the
potential you always knew that you had
the potential was validated by all these
other people that said you were good
took meetings with you based on the
script you know that kind of stuff that
those are meaningful things you go over
to 20th Century Fox you're meeting with
a head of
you know the vice-president of
production who read your script and
wants to take a meeting with you it's a
pretty big deal and you don't have any
agent or representation that's a big
deal there you feel good about that so
to lose all of that and start from
Sparrow
it was I was upset I loved the script
when I read the first draft that he had
made it it stayed with me for hours and
I knew that that was always where I
wanted to go was to make films that you
know I that were moved moving to me I
didn't have to sit there and think about
it it's just like it's stirred in my
head so that was the motivation to get
back to where we were by doing that film
so what I wanted you know obviously when
I created that movie I wanted it to
launch our career I wanted it to change
everything that the doors were gonna
open because now all the relationships
that I have been building up for the
last three and a half years would see a
product of something that I was able to
do on a micro budget and you got
critical acclaim and it did really well
in sales and yet we were talking to
people at Netflix the head Ted I forgot
his last name but the CEO I mean this is
still when they were smaller and still
open but they can't I mean I wrote to
him in an email and he handed me off to
one of the yeah I mean it was it was
serious it wasn't like you know I know
all these things I mean it's it's
frustrating for filmmakers gonna hear
that because everybody wants that but at
the same time my idea of producing was
to get into the Hollywood studio system
and become a big producer and have you
know lots of money but I didn't realize
that in essence what we were doing was
we were separating ourselves from that
part of the industry
not that I reject them or think that
they're wrong or anything like that I I
mean they their business they can do
whatever they want but today coming
forward six films later and we have
Internet and we have alternative media
and you have other methods and ways in
which you can reach thousands of people
very quickly with little to no overhead
that's that's the sweet spot for me as
an independent film producer I mean you
have to imagine there are also companies
now that exists kind of like ours not as
production companies but companies out
of New York and elsewhere that have a
team of people and an overhead and a set
budget that actually go out and do the
same work that I'm actually doing as a
producer one-on-one with all of these
different people in the alternative
media because the the subject matter
speaks directly to that group of people
whereas in a larger system where you
have more overhead you have more risk
you have a lot of other things you have
to spend millions of dollars to ensure
that you're gonna get a delivery on
payout for your investment and your
distributors and all your talent and
everything else that's in there so they
are hiring these companies now to go and
find these groups of people that exist
online in these communities and market
the film to them it's quite interesting
now it's not first tier distribution
level obviously it's not theatrical and
it's not television cable but these
secondary secondary areas like social
work groups and and other groups that
are dealing with causes and and and all
of that they they would have to cast as
wide of a net as possible and spend tens
of millions of dollars to possibly reach
those people where if you go directly to
them today and you have credibility and
you can you create a relationship with
the person who's interviewing you all of
a sudden you're opened up to their
entire audience and we're talking like
thousands of people some of these people
on YouTube have two three four hundred
thousand or more subscribers they also
have patreon which you know is another
and you get email blasts I mean we saw
when we went out and did with the
child's voice or latest film on human
trafficking we went directly to these
individuals and the moment that we did
the inner
it was published and the moment that
that patreon went out we're talking like
hundreds of sales within days on Vimeo
on Vimeo alone and we haven't even gone
to Amazon and done Prime and all of that
so when you're when you're looking at
that and you're seeing the potential
plus the reaction the reactions are
instant with these you know they're
writing comments in the YouTube comments
they're writing them on IMDB they're
writing them on a Vimeo
organically organic growth organic
spread you go on doing keyword search on
Twitter you know and you look at how
none of these people follow you they
don't even follow people that you follow
they heard about it and shared it they
were moved by it you receive comments
you receive emails you hear first-hand
testimonies from people I mean these are
the things that I feel are far more
important than trying to get access to
the industry in their press machine
which is important don't get me wrong
but relying solely on that to make your
message of your movie and your work get
out there so today from 10 years ago to
now I'm not saying you know this
system's wrong but I'm saying there are
other opportunities out there that can
fulfill what you want to do that don't
have to mean going through the Hollywood
media and the Hollywood studio system in
order to achieve what you really want to
do so for me the evolution was one of
feeling I had to be a part of that and
included in it to be important or
successful and instead realizing that my
work and my commitment to it and the
people that it's affecting was the best
that's like the best compliment you
could ever get you know when you read
stories about people who have gone
through some of these hardships not from
a news report but they're personally
telling you that I'm so glad that you
are doing this i-i-i-i've I'm glad that
Hollywood is finally addressing this or
someone out there heard us when you meet
the victims
and the people that have been affected
by a message that you're trying to show
of what's going on out there that is the
most personally at this stage of my
career that is the most rewarding thing
that I have and obviously I would love
to be able to reach a larger group of
people I would love to be able to work
with people in Hollywood ooh you see
what we're doing is important I've been
told by producers who've done big time
series big-time television shows movies
they're like this is exactly the kind of
stuff that we need to be promoting these
are the kinds of stories we need to be
telling we need to educate people on the
realities of the world that's going on
around us so that has become now my
mission I guess it's not a political
agenda it's one of the search of your
journey through yourself and and what
you believe about the world around you
so it's become something bigger it's
become something I guess you could say I
don't want to like freak people out but
it's spiritual in the sense of the human
self in your heart and your mind trying
to find your deeper purpose on this
planet while you're still alive and you
have this human family of 7.2 billion
people in the world that need help they
need help they need to they need honesty
they need art they need we need all the
things we talked about when we need art
we need we don't need to destroy art we
need to promote art and art comes from a
truthful place within you and more we do
that I think the better the world can
get at least I'm trying to do my one
part you know in this little tiny space
in the world that I occupy online and in
reality so I guess you could say that's
been my evolution in the last ten years
of where I saw myself ten years ago and
where I saw myself today and quite
honestly if you had told that guy in
2008 that this is where I'd be today I'd
go nope I don't want that but the guy
that I am today looking back at
you know my younger self I would say
dude go for it
you have everything to gain from this
experience and wherever the cards fall
or the chips may fall you can walk
through it all learning about yourself
learning about the world around you and
affecting people in real and meaningful
ways and that's just me that's that may
not be everybody but I I would say as a
filmmaker if we pride ourselves on
telling stories that matter and mean
something to people then maybe we look
at how we how we tell stories who we
tell stories to and for who who do we
serve who do we go out there to embrace
and partner with to help get this
message out like organizations or
communities online that exists social
workers I mean it doesn't have to all be
social issues stuff but it that it but
it's a human thing to reach out and
connect with others rather than standing
back here and sort of being in the
industry and loved by the industry and
everything else but really that's fine
you know having friends and you know
connecting with others in the industry
and having your peers and your allies
that's great
but really we're looking at how do we
nourish people's minds and hearts how do
we bring out you know when you show
something that's honest and truthful how
you perceive it how he perceives it how
the next person does it's it's a call to
action inside of you it's up to you what
you want to do or what you want to take
from it or don't but the purpose should
be to try to impact someone show
somebody something that they haven't
seen before something that you learned
in the journey of making this movie
about yourself and the world around you
maybe maybe we could do that a little
bit more and focus on that and if we
really do want to change the world for
the better we could start there possibly
and not only impacting others but and I
don't mean to sound selfish but also
finding a reason to keep doing it
ourselves because most people don't make
it
through six plus films they just know
it's too hard yeah you get knocked out
too much you get too many of these
meetings oh it's so great thank you so
much love you and you never hear from
them and then you most people do give up
yeah yeah yeah Jennifer Jennifer
Coolidge is one of my favorite actresses
told me many years ago she goes I only
believe the people who love my work the
ones that are at the ones that hire me
you know everybody says great job
congratulations and and then they don't
never again write you we've all
experienced this so that part of it is
discouraging and you know I got down
quite a bit after my third or fourth
film there was a period of time where it
was just I didn't I wasn't motivated I
wanted to be but I wasn't and it forced
me to take stock of what I was really in
this for would I continue would I go get
a job somewhere else would I leave the
film industry of course I could I mean
you know it's I can leave on my own
terms anytime anybody can but it was
searching from within to find a meaning
for what you cared about life and of
yourself and that expression and the
taking care of this person in here will
manifest outward and I would say that
there was a period of time even as I was
making movies still producing where I
wasn't I you know I focused on the
casting I focused on the logistics I
focused on doing all the tasks and
everything and they still brought good
people together but in this last one
what it taught me more than any of the
other films doing a child's voice not
because it's just the subject matter
but the relationship to the feeling I
had coming through learning about all of
what human trafficking is and how it
impacts all of us everywhere in the seen
and unseen ways inspired me to do the
best job I've ever done producing a film
and had the best experience on set with
the best group of people I've ever had
the opportunity to work with
collectively and they all loved each
other that was that was such a beautiful
thing to watch when you have your cast
and your crew and everybody's already
wanting to do a good job and then you
see it all come together in this
beautiful spirit and and we're talking
like you know 14 hours of work and
they're heading off down the road
dancing in the street and going to get
ice cream and and and I mean we're
talking about like you know a DP and
other people that come from you know
extensive backgrounds some of them very
accomplished I mean they didn't need to
work on our movie in terms of the
trajectory of their career we found
people that were into the art wanted to
do it because of the art of it didn't
look at it as like I'm doing you a favor
but it wasn't that wasn't even the
starting point the starting point was
wow these are really great characters
you guys seem like really good people I
want to do it it wasn't it wasn't a
question when we had like guys a lead
role guy come all the way down from
Fresno on a bus just for the audition
and that was his dedication never been
in a lead role ever in anything of a
feature it's totally green in terms of
you know experience but he had raw
talent he had a spark Angela who played
the co-lead she I saw her in a GoPro
film doing jet skiing and I saw a spirit
in her that I just wanted to see and I
went to her YouTube channel and saw she
was playing guitar and singing she had
like this beauty in her I didn't know
she was gonna be talented or not but her
spirit and her essence of what I saw
felt had something to offer in this and
then once all of us sat down of course
we had different choices forecast and
we're going through all that but
everything just lined up and made this
thing come together and happen and it
worked beautifully in such a way that
when we got to that premiere and this is
the greatest joy that you know the red
carpet for me the red carpet producer I
love your analogy of it I I just it's
it's like the from the moment you read
the script and your journey through this
to create and then you get to that night
and it's just this energy this beautiful
energy of everybody's excitement they're
nervous they're like you know they're
like they're going up to each other on
each other I had people on the outside
who had hired for this premiere -
videographer and a photographer and they
we did an after party they all came with
us they had already gotten paid they
could have gone home you know after the
show and I had a couple of filming one
of them's a filmmaker and she said I
have never been to a place like a
premiere like this we're just everybody
is just so excited and happy and loving
and we were talking about like 400
almost 400 people you know cast crew
their friends and up but but a bunch of
strangers coming in and there was just
this goodwill in in the audience both
during the film and after and they
didn't want to leave they stuck around I
think we ended up closing down Barney's
Beanery at like 1:30 in the morning I
mean that the premiere the film started
like seven something he got out and
whatever and then and then there's just
hours of people sticking around and like
talking and you just see like that this
is what it this is what makes it
worthwhile I mean into in terms of
making these kinds of films and and the
moment you read the script to seeing it
up on a big screen and a large audience
of people and there
they're just they're enjoying your work
for the first time and you can kind of I
mean you can look but you kind of get a
sense in the vibe and all that it's just
beautiful
it just it validates that to me
validates everything that you just did
and how people are emotionally impacted
afterwards not what they come up and say
to you necessarily as a compliment I
watched everybody else out there and how
the actors and actresses and the
families were so proud of them and just
like this is this is what we're trying
to do this is what what to me and maybe
that's an idealistic thing maybe
intentions he'll change that but I have
never I wish I could do that every
single day everywhere with new audiences
all the time and bringing everybody
together it's just a it's a really
beautiful beautiful feeling and in it
and it's those are the great memories
they have I believe you told your two
actors Angela and Joey that but they
should kind of cherish this time because
they're in a really interesting space
right now and I was wondering how you
could apply that same analogy to
producers other filmmakers yeah so I
told them I mean you're young you know
they're they're extremely young they're
19 and 22 and I said you don't get many
opportunities like this not only as a
lead role but to do something that not
only you're proud of but that other
people have validated both in the
industry and outside and I said you need
a strike while it's hot because these
opportunities don't come along every day
sometimes it's once in a career where
you can move up to the next level if
you're smart and what I mean by that is
you you need to strike while the iron's
hot
you know because two years will go by
like that and and and it'll be over you
know it won't people will take a look at
you you will have a body of work and you
have critical acclaim and validation
from different points of view about a
success of a movie now some people
define success by the money that it
generates at the box office but other
people look at it and go oh wow you
sustained an entire performance in a
feature film that
that has this and what what makes it
unique for them is that they they have a
lot to learn but that they have an
opening a door that is opened and it
will close but as a producer what does
that mean for me or any artist film
maker in general is that you do need to
strike while the iron is hot and you
need to have a plan going into it a game
plan of how you're gonna attack getting
your movie out there in whatever
capacity that you're capable of doing
that's the one thing I don't think about
you know like some people want to wait
and you know kind of wait for that
perfect storm and everything but I
actually think that once you've gotten
to the point where you're satisfied with
where your film is like in terms of the
picture lock and all of the elements and
you're and you're going okay this is the
film we've created get it out there and
you don't give up you you try it one way
doesn't work you come up with another
idea you go over here and look at this
maybe this maybe that maybe this you
exhaust every option that you have
simply for the fact that it's your baby
you own it you're gonna own it for the
rest of your life and you might as well
do everything you possibly can both now
and in the future to ensure that the
film has a place that you can be proud
of and if you can't which is fine
learn from it take the lessons that you
learned from it and try to do something
else
not necessarily abandon what you but
take that as your your learning block
you know you're you in other words one
film is not going to define you one
moment is not going to define you but if
you don't take advantage of it to try to
fulfill it to its fullest potential you
will not learn anything and you're
seeding that over to other people to
determine the fate of it whereas if
you take what's available to you and
what you believe in and you innovate as
opposed to locking in and saying it can
only be this way it can only go through
a distributor it can only I an have to
have Lionsgate I have to have this actor
or it's not this and so for them from
the actor to the producer it's incumbent
upon yourself to understand even without
experience to understand that this is a
very unique opportunity for you to learn
through your craft what to do better the
next time
in all those moments that are
challenging to you is the greatest
period of growth that you can ever have
if you do not look at it that way it may
not be the right fit for you to go down
this road because adversity is always
going to be staring you at the face even
with a 40 or 50 million dollar or 100
million dollar budget I've talked to
producers who tell me no the challenges
is always the same you're always gonna
be limited just from me looking out
they're up to what they have I go wow
yeah what could I do with a road 1 you
know budget wow that's amazing
but even still those producers and I've
talked to one of them have challenges a
court that are you know reflective of
their current environment there's always
going to be time that you're gonna lose
there's always going to be money that's
going to be an issue but it just it's
just scaled up it's the same these are
the same issues to just scaled up so as
a producer it's my job that if I believe
in what I'm doing to not give up but
also if I'm going to be a successful
producer and do six movies and some hit
some don't summer receive well some
aren't you know if I'm committed to what
I'm doing I've got to learn from those
mistakes and here's the thing you own
that film you always go back and read it
if you see that there's another story
there that you didn't see at the time
we've done that with two of our movies
we're doing one of them now
a young man's future about schizophrenia
and college students we're coming back
and man with fresh eyes it's like a
beautiful story more powerful than ever
before and it's just story because all
the elements were there is just how you
arrange the story what you focus on
maybe where some things meander a little
bit cut that out
concise story points and I've seen it
now like twice so I know that those are
possibilities as well and we're gonna go
out to a whole new group of people we're
not gonna go back and retread all the
critics and say hey this is the
director's cut I mean maybe if they want
to review it sure but there's other
audiences out there that we can we can
hit with a new release of a movie or a
recut and that's just through the
discovery of looking at the footage and
seeing that there's another story there
there was an example of this Krisha was
an independent film that was written it
was written and I think it came up in
Vanity Fair like three four years ago
about how this filmmaker
I can't remember his name he he didn't
edit out of he did an edit of the film
and it wasn't received well and he was
just like I failed and then he went back
and he retooled it and made this
compelling drama about a woman an older
woman coming home to Thanksgiving yeah
extremely extremely well done but the
first cut of that movie was not the one
you saw and he said it just me and heard
all over the place so he just started
switching things up throwing throwing
scenes that were written for here threw
him to the front change things around
paired it down to this this there's this
build of an explosion right an emotional
explosion because you're seeing the the
the part of her that is this this
troubled individual and all of her vices
and addictions sure with trying to
reconcile you know what she really wants
which is the closest to her family
anyway it it
it speaks to those things where there is
a story there there was always a story
there it's just you have to find it
because obviously you know they say the
one you wrote the one you shot and the
one that's edited but then there's also
the one that how its received and that
feedback that people give you even if
it's diametrically opposed to what your
vision is or is quote not positive you
can learn from how people are responding
not because what they're saying is an
accurate assessment but there's
something in there that is is not
working for them logically when they're
watching a story and if you hear that
from like four or five different people
then you got to kind of like say okay
what's what where's the truth in all of
what they're telling you and so you take
that and you learn that lesson you go
okay what's next
actors actresses film makers producers
you gotta go what's next
do you believe in that sort of you know
cliche saying that it's no longer your
film once it's out there it's no it's
now that it belongs to the audience yeah
I know that's such a never really I've
never really thought of it that way I
mean you can I guess but it should to me
it's kind of like a shared experience
you know you you Denzel Washington
talked about this years ago you know I'm
gonna you know making a film is like
baking a cake or a pie or something he
said you're gonna bake it you're gonna
put all these ingredients in you're
gonna bake it and then you're gonna
serve it to people and some people are
gonna go wow this is the best cake I've
ever tasted other people go wasn't that
good but all you can do is bake the cake
it's a great analogy yeah I just free
watched a million-dollar million dollar
baby and I just felt that like Hilary
Swank was she was made for that role
like I can't imagine any other actor in
that role right and and I had forgotten
about how emotional it was and we
interviewed someone and they we're
talking about it's like you know what I
want to see it and so and then I you go
online you go under the trailer and you
and you see just
the divided nature I mean how could
someone not like especially her
character it's so excellent but subject
it's yeah subjective zuv the
interpretation of the individual hey you
know what if I mean there's another
movie I saw years ago the follow-up from
the director of drive Oh Nikolas red
whining resin yeah he did one called
only God forgives with Ryan Gosling
right and that was panned across the
board and I personally I find that movie
so fulfilling now there's probably gonna
be people that listeners it was a
terrible film but it was saying things
that are very difficult and very ugly
about this particular world that he
brought us into and critics didn't like
it there are some esoteric things you
know I would agree
you know concede that this is it's not a
typical American movie the way it's
paced the way it's edited the dialogue
is very sparse but there's a feeling and
an undertow to the whole thing I mean
but you go online and you look at Amazon
you would have thought this is the worst
movie ever made ever by some people's
opinions it doesn't necessarily mean
that your the opposite is true but it's
just subjective to that person's the
bear world and what they're wanting to
see they like drive for a number of
reasons try this one was totally the
opposite it was even darker there's a
darker world an underbelly of like
prostitution and you know smuggling and
drugs and murder and but I mean just
just a criminal underground world in
Thailand and it's scary because it's
it's presented in a very realistic way
there's violence there's gore there's
there's nobody really there that you
relate to and that I think was the
underlying issue and that film is that
there's really nobody there to root for
because Ryan Gosling is
victim of his mother and his mother runs
the whole show that arguably is one of
the best performances of a female that
I've ever seen I mean just for acting
purposes in terms of daring and
Christian I was at Kristin Scott Thomas
I love her yeah yeah whenever that's
somebody that you would never expect in
that role and she just like blew me away
with the the audacity she was in life as
a house and here she's this very
together composed you know like a lot of
good and in this one she's like a
narcissistic mother who is it's gross
but she's she's she's amazing that that
was another level of acting I'd never
seen at her yeah and then people are you
know online just saying I didn't like
this I don't like these people this
isn't good acting you know I don't know
but again it's subjective to the
audience and you can only you can only
make the film and you know when you make
something that you know is going to get
a polarizing reaction you know I mean
you hear that other sort of things I
just want someone to react to it I don't
really care if they love it or hate it
and I think that's important if you're
okay with that I think it you can't
always I know somebody I talked to years
ago that I work with you said oh I hate
indie film there's never a happy ending
it's confusing it's like I can't stand
those people and I thought that's why I
love indie film though I I don't want to
know that I don't be thinking about it
for weeks out you know yeah I don't want
it all neat and then there's a the great
80s soundtrack and there people are
holding hands walking off in the sunset
so but if you make something and I know
all the films that you and Edgar Michael
Bravo of Maine they touch on some very
intense subjects and I think going into
that you know that it's gonna get a
reaction for people I think I think if
you if is an artist you've uh you've
gotten a reaction out of somebody you've
done your job at minimum if they ignore
you and they don't care and just think
yeah you know okay that's that hurts
that that to me hurts more when I see
people online like you know
writing horrible stuff about our movies
and I'm just like wow this really
affected you you know in a way that I
don't agree with it I'll try to
understand you know where they're coming
from and and and I and and some of my
concede I mean I'm not like writing back
to them but some of them I can see they
have valid you know issues but some of
it also is very personal and short and
so their emotions like I mean I've had
certain people obviously go online and I
mean like of all the things you had to
say about our film you attacked it on
these merits that have nothing to do
with the movie you know but it's gonna
happen if people are people and the
internet obviously gives a lot of cover
and antipathy to people who wouldn't
dare come up to you and say it in person
but they can't from behind their
keyboard and you know there's an agenda
with every comment whether it's their
own agenda or whether it's to discredit
you or whatever there's an agenda and if
you can see it for what it is but
sometimes you don't always know what it
is yeah you just I mean if your provokes
a response and it and it incites a
response in you again you just have to
realize okay am I gonna really spend the
time does this person want to have a
conversation with me and ask me certain
things are they wanting to tell me who I
am and and that they know what you know
right that's where you just kind of have
to go okay that's just that's
what comes first the budget or the
script script script dictates the budget
script is your heart and soul the spine
of the whole thing that you're gonna
build off of the foundation of
everything that you're gonna lay on top
of it and if you have money first and
you're writing to the budget of that I
think your creativity is is paramount
and then dealing with in the realities
of you know what's what resources are
available to you right and then you
start talking about money and how you're
gonna fulfill that vision but if the
vision is coming from a monetary at me
personally I I've had more money on some
of my other films didn't mean I did a
better job producing in fact my third
film mother's red dress I had more money
than any of the other ones and it was my
worst job producing why because I
because I thought that by having more
money to pay more money to each position
and person that was working on it I was
just gonna get better talent and
therefore I took my my my better part of
myself out of the equation just that it
was gonna be solved by money and I
learned a very valuable lesson on that
we got the film done and everything was
great and it worked out fine but I I saw
dollars and that I could get this kind
of DP and it didn't translate into
success for the project in fact the
person that I brought on once that DP
left the project for another project in
the middle of shooting yeah I brought in
somebody else that had less equipment
less experience and he did a fantastic
job because his motivation was correct
so so if you if you look at it from this
standpoint if you have money and you're
gonna pay people right I mean we all
want to get paid and we gotta work to
live and all that but but if that is the
focus first then I think that the you're
doing the opposite it's like okay we've
got a marketing campaign we can do now
let's find a script if it's you know the
kind of content that we want to sell as
opposed to what
from within do you think you didn't
screen the people properly because they
were so ready to take the Paycheck that
you didn't see the commitment um I think
it was a combination of that and just
thinking that maybe I had you know was
trying to I think I I took my vigilance
off and and and not qualifying people on
eleven no I had a great time working
with all of those individuals but I
could have avoided a lot of problems had
I had done better vetting of my cast and
my crew that's not to say I regret any
of it because it was a learning
experience and we got a film done and we
did a really good job with it and it
impacted a lot of people but in terms of
my job as a producer I I stepped away
from certain things and just figured
they were gonna take care of themselves
because I had more money that was a
mistake I made so on a movie like a
child's voice where do you spend the
most money
well Cass crew and all the logistics the
locations the food and equipment and
insurance and all that and you know it
got it all like it goes into the
personnel it's it's all the
below-the-line and but but not for us I
mean it's it's a labor of love on that
point you know our stuff is not to pay
ourselves that's just me
but but but all of it goes into the the
planning the implementation and then
also what I try to do is I always look
at the budget every couple of days and
start to try to figure out where I can
get donations where I can get discounts
where I can where I can smartly schedule
things better so that we're not spending
double the money to get the same thing
that we could in one day over here if we
if we plan it better or smartly write it
you know write it in a way that doesn't
require
you just got a look at what you're
trying to say right what are you trying
to say with the scene with each scene do
we need really need to stretch it out or
can we consolidate it here and maybe
combine some things so it's it's a team
effort between me and Edgar but mine is
always to try to find things that are
reducing costs and overhead every single
time well you had the hotel and it was
that somewhere in like Riverside or in
Riverside so be cheaper than LA I'm sure
right and in Riverside is cheaper to
film with permits and everything and you
still have to do all the paperwork and
everything else but it's not it's not
expensive they it's gone up a little bit
in the last couple of years because they
had more filming out there now but this
the county of Riverside is fantastic
those two women that run it they're
fantastic as long as they're there I
think they'll do really really well City
of Riverside is independent of that the
county of Riverside opens you up to so
many other things they have location
services that they'll help you with we
went to seven or eight different motels
in different groups and I drove out
there and I lobbied all of them like
sorry huh what's that like
oh it's difficult you're gonna meet a
lot of a lot of people that don't care
and and but some people when you talk to
them and just tell them what you're
doing and what it's about and and and
you know the realities of what you're
dealing with I'm dealing with a crew of
eight people I've got you know this many
actors coming in I I need this kind of
room can you help us out we had help we
would not have been able to make the
film without taking out more money to
and away from something else potentially
where I might have to raise some later
if it wasn't for that manager at that
particular Hotel who gave us a discount
because he was personally invested in
that issue and and you never know how
things are gonna come but that came from
the relationship from his brother who
knew a person who had endorsed their
previous film and a letter of writing
just so happened that he knew who he was
told these guys yeah whatever they're
doing if they're backed by this guy you
help him out
whatever you can but it wasn't it was
who he was the owner and the heart that
he had for this issue I mean he came all
the way out from Riverside with his
family and his mother and father to the
premier Wow and continued to help us
afterwards by taking us into this hotel
Association the Asian American hotels
owner associate nobody knows about this
but eighteen thousand numbers one one
out of every two hotels in the country
and one of their core tenants of what
they're they're fighting against is
human trafficking in their chains and
they have a program this is like a top
program where all of their members have
to receive training from the top down
down to the housemates about how to
correctly identify the signs of human
trafficking how to document it and how
to get local law enforcement and local
services governing services involved to
get it out of there and still help the
kid because the kid's life is in danger
once that person knows that they're
tried they're they're trafficking in
that and that you know because they may
go somewhere else but they may do
something else to more crime may come in
so these are the things that like when
you connect with people because of what
you're driven by you speak truthfully to
that and I saw a couple of people that
you know no matter what I said to them
you just saw the lights were out oh yeah
they're just like uh-huh sure okay yeah
we'll talk and you don't hear anything
else and so it's like a day or two or
three that I had to go out there and
talk and and and meet people and leave
cards and follow up but you're talking
about the difference between you know
one hundred and seven dollars a night
per room versus less which enables you
to do more with your budget and your
crew and maybe add a day or whatever or
you know you you you don't have to worry
about how the hell am I gonna pay for
this so it's it's really valuable to go
out there like as a producer that's what
I'd love to do on the hands-on guy I'd
like to get involved in everything the
locations all of it I I try to some
people take the there's one guy mark
Stowell off I love the guy he's like beg
barter and steal right and and to me
it's like okay well I'd rather not steal
and
hey III don't want to beg but I
definitely want to align myself with
people that kind of like what we do like
a Grateful Dead concert you can barter
you know hey how much spaghetti exactly
but the thing is though I'm sure you
could probably see in the ones that
showed you some signs of life like this
person's gonna be easy to work with
whereas others it's all about the dollar
signs yeah you can just feel that
they're not gonna be willing to hey you
know we're gonna run an hour late you
know I mean it was that some of what you
were dealing with gauging their
willingness yeah because like if if this
was the starting point right this is the
other thing I was kind of mentioned
earlier about you know being fixated on
a person or an idea or a way that you
want to do it you just have to adapt and
go that that's not who they are you know
and just and save yourself the trouble
because anything after that you're gonna
have to be asking them for permission to
do all sorts of things and what you want
to do is not to hide it from them but
you want a partner you want somebody who
understands gives you like when we
wanted to write an additional scene that
pool scene right right that night we
came up with that while we were filming
and he said yeah go for it oh yeah we
didn't have to like you know sit there
and negotiate you know something with
him they were just like yeah you guys do
whatever you need to do they loved us
they loved they loved seeing the film we
brought him into the room we let them
you know watch the film of course they
get bored after like 20 minutes cuz
that's how everybody does all this like
this is it yeah but but making them a
part of it and and showing appreciation
you know we put their name in the
credits
it's very special thanks and and you
know we just it's just as a gesture and
so if you put a gesture out there and
someone gives you a gesture back
that's it may not be everything that you
want or envisioned for your movie but
you know work with those people because
they're going to be there for you when
things don't go right you know the way
you planned it and you may need
something else to happen that you didn't
anticipate or something that comes up
and and they I mean they were just so
giving to us it was it was really a
was really a great thing so if you are
driving out to Riverside I don't know if
you're working a full day and then
you're having to get in your car but
that hands-on approach versus this thing
I keep throwing out which is the red
carpet producer and I know I'm making
light of it but I remember when he told
it to me years ago and it never forgot
it totally and I was wonder if you could
just explain yeah here's what it is well
so there was a very my former mentor who
told me that there were a lot of
producers out there that want to have
their name in a film you know and they
want to walk the red carpet with a
starlet and you know it's kind of more
it's a more sort of status thing as
opposed to the the producer that will be
married to that project for the rest of
their life and it gave me some examples
of that so the red carpet producer I
mean is the one that you know it's it's
the glamor life it's the it's the one
where you know you're you're sort of
just there is a figure that you were a
part of this yes but you were just sort
of there to cash in on the on the
experience of it as opposed to the
filmmaking process and that's not every
producer but there are a ton of them out
there they you know they'll help make a
movie and they'll put their name in the
credits and and they really just want
the kind of the social benefits of all
of that to kind of play and do their
thing I don't know if that is that
answer that it does I was thinking if
someone know comes with a checkbook and
I know this sounds very it sort of
callous but and they you know that
that's their very defined role and they
are like yes I have the money I just
want to invest in this then I feel like
they get a pass but not everybody comes
with that I realized right and there are
a lot of red carpet you insert any title
yeah there's a lot of people in there
they just want to you know say they made
a movie and and that's fine you know but
it's it's it's not producing I don't
think there there are line producers who
are amazing people and there are
creative producers that are amazing
people and there are executive producers
that are amazing people but if you just
show up with it I mean obviously if
somebody came to me with money and said
hey we want to invest but I'd really it
really had to be though that we have
shared shared principles sort of in the
sense that like Who I am as a person I
don't want to just be taking somebody's
money not knowing who they are not
knowing I mean I wouldn't get involved I
wouldn't start a business with you right
unless you and I Karen kind of like
talked through some things and kind of
go oh yeah we feel kind of the same way
about this world and sure you're
bringing X and I'm bringing Y to this to
this vision that we're gonna create and
do something but if somebody's just
showing up handed money and you just
don't you know it looks like mmm and
they're flipping about it yeah sounds
good yeah yeah yeah oh it's a great idea
you know keep me posted keep me posted I
mean I I've met so many of those people
that like they'd literally walk around
and actually the the thing that kicked
off when our fantasy girl was I now
believed that that's what we had we had
a person like that I value even offered
money before like lots of money
through debt instruments you'll hear
about that that term a lot and and it
can get really tricky because ultimately
the the loan that you're taking out to
finance your movie it's on you to repay
Oh God and it's not so it's not it's not
really financing in terms of venture
capital which is risk it's I'm gonna get
paid whether this movie makes money or
not and it'll be off of your back and
your name is on the loan it's not the
person providing the financing we've
we've looked at all the paperwork and
there are there are many different
instruments out there they're there you
know that are backed by banks and in
reality for an independent film producer
this is this is one of the dangers I
don't think there's been many people
that have done this but when you're a
big studio and you have a whole slate of
movies and you can afford to lose money
in some where others will make up for
the the losses of the other you can play
that game
when you're talking about one movie and
five million dollars and five million
dollars being in your name and you're
responsible for paying that back within
a certain number of years irregardless
of how the film turns out irregardless
if a distributor buys your movie up only
to hold it I mean there's all sorts of
things that can go wrong that prevent
you from getting that and that money
back so it's best to work with people
who share your vision who believe that
you're capable of implementing this goal
this dream this thing you have not just
on a business plan but when they sit
across from you and they're asking you
questions like a smart investor would
who's cautious where they're gonna put
their money that they're not just out
there ready to sign up and you know
let's make your movie but yet at the
same time there isn't this other process
that it goes through it's kind of back
to that validation when you're a young
actor out here and somebody say hey you
got a good look hop in the car you know
but it's the same it's the same thought
process you you you if you're investing
money into a film you want to know who
you're getting involved with on both
sides of that table because in at the
end of the day if everything goes wrong
you don't want to be countersued or you
don't want to sue you don't want to
countersue you'd rather go hey we tried
we're gonna you know it didn't work you
know this is it was all written out
obviously you do the contracts and
everything else and everybody knows what
what the investor and the credited
investor is and all that kind of stuff
but at the end of the day you don't want
to have troubles when things don't go
right you want to be able to you know go
hey we all got in this together we have
the best intentions working together
we're people and we you know I need you
you need me if this is what we want to
do to make money or tell this story or
both hopefully and if it doesn't go the
way we think it is then we have to learn
from it and move on that's what
investors that's what good investors do
the good investors are people who have
made bad investments and they've learned
from making those bad
investments what not to do the next time
around makes them a little bit more
cautious maybe a little bit more cynical
but the only thing that you have at that
point is just yourself and what you're
bringing to the table and if that person
sees you as the values to what they're
trying to achieve and go yeah you you
reflect all of the qualities that I'm
looking for in people that I know in
other industries who invest in products
and materials and businesses you share
the same qualities that these
entrepreneurs do and and those are the
kind of relationships that I want to go
forward with and I've been very blessed
to have those I learned a lot of lessons
early on red carpet producer ready to
write that check keep me posted you know
and and nothing is on the record ever
you you will know like they can never
put anything in writing for you
everything will be a phone call let's
have a conversation yeah let's talk
about it a phone calls no good and
especially as you get closer to meeting
their their their stated demands or not
demands but objectives that they need to
have in place in order for that
investment to happen what a lot of these
guys do is they as they get people like
you and me around and they will they'll
get a retainer from somebody they get a
monthly retainer to pitch projects so if
you've got somebody who's willing to get
involved with you and you are getting
retainer from a group that's looking to
do the financing the whether it be the
bank or the banker or somebody else what
they're doing is they're basically
presenting you a slate of projects and
the status reports every month and
saying here's where we're moving on this
as if this date will have this and if
projects come and go and drop off well
then these people are getting that money
to vet them saying well they you know
whatever reason they make up to this
individual and meanwhile they could be
telling you everything is going fine and
yeah yeah we've seen that a couple of
times it's a it's a con and it's a scam
but the the real con is the one that
they're doing and they're getting the
retainer for the the worst one is when
the filmmaker commits and has done so
through a process really where there's
no
verified paper trail if anything that's
been said or and yeah it's bad it's bad
I tell pretty people if you can't put
something in writing with anybody yeah
don't get involved with them that's a
red flag what are your top ten tips for
producing a movie top ten that's wow
script passionate about the script
attack everything you do with reckless
abandon in terms of your passion and
work with people that you get along with
you have mutual respect for both in your
profession as well as there's a personal
identification you don't have to agree
with everything but a shared shared
principle about how to work how you want
to work it's three right yeah four don't
rush things don't make artificial
deadlines that don't mean anything other
than what you think in your head and
that means like for example don't rush
to get a film done cutting corners
whether it be in the pre-production
production or post-production all to
meet whatever deadlines you have set
that you have to hit in order if it's a
distributor giving you a deadline okay
if it's you trying to get this one
festival got a really way whether or not
it's worth it to cut those corners and
the reason why I say is because in that
haste to get there you will forget
certain things that are important and
it's not about just racing to the
deadline it's thinking your plan through
very clearly so ties into that fourth
fourth or fifth wire which is start from
the end start from the very end and work
your way back don't start here and go
forward without knowing where you're
gonna end up and seeing what that place
looks like at the very end when you
arrive to the finished part of your
or the distribution of your film really
and it's like it's like a an objective a
clear objective this is where I need to
be at this stage and you should be and
it should be a logical conclusion
because everything should flow forward
as it flows backwards as well Wow okay
you won't miss anything that way review
your budget look at your budget daily
all the time even if you're not a guy
who writes up the budget or a woman who
writes up the budget whatever it is
study it become a student of it because
you here's what it will happen and I
just know this from my own experience we
had a problem on the last film piece of
equipment got broken and would have
stopped the whole filming but knowing
that I had what I had in the budget and
knowing what I had available I knew that
we could get through it and I was able
to make a split-second decision to start
calling and getting while I was in
Riverside I had to go to LA and it was
five o'clock and everything closed at
6:00 so I had to put game mode on I
wasn't gonna get over there so I had to
go who do we know in LA that we can have
once we purchase it they can go pick it
up and I can go pick it up from him
later that night so that I could drive
it back to set but all of that I did
under calm when what had just unfolded
in front of me could have been a
potential disaster but because I knew
how much money I had I knew what I
needed to do I knew where to start and I
kept and we and within 30 minutes we had
an answer in a solution and it was done
so so study the budget it will benefit
you in ways that you don't even know at
the time so that's six six well I'm sure
I'm sure there are more no I think that
the the most important thing is to have
trust in the people that you work with
and that is incumbent on you in other
words you set the table
and everybody else that you invite to
that table is going to be participating
in it so that your you know people that
you're gonna work with for the actors
and this is just when you were doing in
micro budget you don't have lawyers and
you don't have these big you know like
people to control the behavior of others
don't necessarily go for the most
talented if it's gonna cause you a
headache if you know it's gonna cause
you a headache and see red flags I meet
with all the talent one on one after the
audition after the callback after the
final callback some of them don't like
that process that's fine but the fourth
and final one is the meeting one-on-one
and I have to know where their
motivations are what kind of person they
are not as an actor but as a person
who's gonna be a person on set that I'm
gonna be in close quarters with I'm
going to be working with four hours long
at a time
so just think and if you don't find who
you want and it doesn't sit it doesn't
agree with you in here keep looking keep
looking till the very end go to every
avenue that you can i I did this with
our leads we had we had tons of talented
actors and through the process you know
it whittled itself down and the
opportunity presented itself because I
didn't give up and in stop looking and I
found people that I just like loved and
from their profession to their to their
person and it's in it and I would work
with them again in a heartbeat because
if I have a role I'll do it you know
they're just great human beings and
they're wonderfully talented so I say
we're at seven eight nine and ten I
think that well I think just have two
more two more okay gosh allow yourself
to evolve with the work that you're
doing in other words what you thought
once when you started and what happens
there on out let that be your journey
that guides you in other words let that
part of the process enrich you and give
you that valuable feedback that you want
and need in order to grow as a human
being in order to grow as an artist and
in order to grow as a filmmaker I can't
say enough about this because I think
it's often that we ignore these things
about that were human beings first and
that we have certain sensitivities and
things that bother us and issues that
come up and we all are trying if our
goal and our focus is about the work and
the relationship to it in both ourselves
and the people that we're bringing to
that table you can achieve so much more
I personally believe this just having
the experience of doing it you can
achieve so much more people will work
that little extra harder that you always
wanted them to do without asking because
you're leading by example and you've
brought people into that mix that have
the same same characteristic within
themselves as all of a sudden oh this
person's like this this person's like
this this pretty oh I'm among people
like me and they were all doing the same
thing where you have a sound guy who's
like carrying bags out of things that
are not his and being there to help you
and yeah it's just this is what what
makes it worthwhile it's not the
struggle and the all the hardships and
everything else that you have to deal
with that's fine but to override
overcome all of that and deal with it
head-on make it make it come from within
you and let that idea and that
inspiration that passion flow and have
other people come into it who feel that
passion in you and are inspired by it
it's like this is why I got into
filmmaking I got into it for the art and
I'm hoping that that art will give me an
opportunity for more
a greater art or whatever it is but this
is that's probably the most important
thing I can say is that it's allow
yourself allow yourself to learn from
the process and don't be so dogged and
fixated on a specific vision that it's
not about being contrary in' or or you
know throwing out what you believe but
let that belief system evolve let it
grow deeper let it get richer let it
enrich you and the people that you're
working from because at the end of the
day at the end of all of this when I am
an old man regardless of where and up I
have all these beautiful memories of
working with people and remembering
those moments on set and how I felt and
and that is like getting to relive your
life a second time and enjoy it so I
know that maybe nine that's okay but
that that's two-in-one right now I was
so excellent so I think then that's why
with your last film I know you have two
more so a child's voice that you felt
like even at that premiere and you're
like basically closing down barn
Barney's Beanery that you felt this
energy that maybe other projects it was
good good times but there was something
different maybe yes you went by those
whatever saying I like the work guide me
in the material and my belief system in
what we were doing with this movie and
and the good it could do first it wasn't
about being a filmmaker in the in the in
the sense of producing and and all the
functional stuff everybody did their job
they came with their tools to do a great
job and and so it was more about that
emotion and they and that feeling of
having created something that everybody
was really proud of in themselves not
for just the craft of it it was this
like we did some we did something oh my
god it affected people oh my god and and
you know grown women coming out and
crying and holding on to our actors and
saying I didn't know that this this
existed and that this happened and and
they don't know each other I mean she's
coming up but there was a strong
reaction I go that is so valuable as a
human human thing to connect with
another human being that that is quote
not your own and it spoke to a deeper
thing about the movie which in the
child's voice is the calling of the
child within us and the answer to the
child that is not you or yours to say I
will protect you I will help you I will
risk my life because that that in itself
is is our mammal part the human part of
us that makes us different from a
reptile do you think the film business
is fair
film industry well then do I think
Hollywood is fair no but I don't think
it has to be and what I mean by that is
that they have a right to run their
operation as they see fit there are
consequences to that obviously
exclusivity and digital world obviously
in the last 10 years is obviously
changed you went from you know
Blockbuster Video to dvd-by-mail to
streaming and now production company
same thing one company that's phase one
it's a transitional phase we're in a
transformational time so I'm not there
to tell Hollywood what to do not to do
they're gonna follow their model as they
see fit I think they have certain
agendas that they want to get out there
and that's fine they're welcome to do
that but I I would believe that the only
time in Hollywood that there was ever an
opportunity for independent filmmakers
to be mainstream was in a moment of
crisis during the 60s and 70s because of
television being in everyone's home the
decline of a box office era because they
had pretty much been doing the same
stuff right all the time is the same and
so younger audiences were going in who
they were trying to hit and they didn't
know who Cary Grant was they just saw an
old guy and then we're kind of at that
point now where the youth is so
connected online Tom Hanks and Meryl
Streep and all those and they're they're
kind of like their legacy right iconic
in terms of their brand and their value
but they don't mean anything to this
younger generation there's no relation
to Fort I mean they can go back and look
at Forrest Gump but they didn't watch
for his gum when they were a child and
make that attachment to Tom Hanks as
they were watching him grow up in front
of our eyes on the screen so they're
gonna have to do it they're gonna deal
with it however they deal with it
I think the fairness that people want in
a system that is not fair you can spend
your time fighting against it or you can
spend that same motivation and time
doing something to create your your way
and you don't know where it'll end up I
mean I would say like if I started like
ten years ago and where I am today are
these six movies I'm glad that I owned
the rights to all of them because it
hasn't even gotten out there today like
if I think in terms of the film industry
and the windows and the you know day and
date and all that kind of like you get
lost in all of that it's it's what they
have done to set the table but if you're
an entrepreneur and you're a filmmaker
and you're an innovator and you're
thinking about like what can I do this
system over here for the most part you
got to have access and entry points and
all sorts of things to get in and then
move up but you may not get to do your
art I mean I want people everybody
should should go for it right I'm
telling everybody go for it
but if it doesn't work try something
else go directly to the audience go
directly to the communities that are
talking about your issue create
something that is different and unique
from the other things that are being
presented don't try to be the new hip
cool Tarantino you know I mean I
understand that people have like they
they watch that and they want to imitate
it and and and they may agree with it
too you know it may be something like I
really love these movies great take an
action genre and maybe take it into a
story that is not being covered not
being served underserved people
underserved groups underserved issues
that are not even talked about in the
mainstream talked about in Hollywood
you'llyou'll standout uniquely maybe if
you make enough money possibly but look
at and I want to say it like here's
perfect example Westworld
season one was phenomenal I mean that's
really about the child rebelling against
its abusers I mean if you want to go
into the the psychological stuff is that
you know as they become more aware
conscious free choice free will and
and basically throwing out their captors
or killing them and that's a really dark
world but that's it's kind of like the
1% versus the 99 if you will or the
power powerful over the powerless and
these are these are you know slaves
basically for sex for murder for us okay
yeah black mirror and black mirror is
talking about you know where we could be
going with technology and our humanity
and showing you the darker elements and
kind of waking up going you know what
that's not that far like they're they're
kind of this sci-fi but in reality are
we really that far away if in the
observable realities that we see today
so I think that the responsibility
really does not rely on the parent
Hollywood to take care of you as so much
you have to become the adult not to lead
them but to create your mark in this
world and if more people do that then
you create a little bit more of a
balance where there's a lot of art going
on over here and people are paying
attention in mass and maybe this group
over here that's losing money on doing
the same thing over and over again turns
its head and goes hey like we did George
Lucas George Lucas all all at Steven
Spielberg all of those guys were result
of film school innovative experimental
film and film school David Lynch how can
we ask for say Z I mean it just and the
list goes on
so when you look at it in those terms
everything is not going to always be the
same as it always was and when you have
this disruptive technology and if not
just talking about in some kind of
vacuum it's real application to connect
with people and to be able to go
directly to the people that want to hear
what you have to say because over here
they have you know everything kind of
locked up I mean you can get in there
I'm not saying it's bad to try and
and try to get your agent your manager
and getting you know like the pitch
meeting and all that I think that's
fantastic but if you're not getting that
response that you want then it's on you
to say I don't have to hate these people
over here I don't have to be anti
anything it's not what this is about is
not about tearing down the power
structure it's actually about creating
your own power structure and amassing
that with other people that are
like-minded because you can all find
each other and start making films
together start telling these stories
start doing it with other people that's
how we're getting our success we're
doing it with others
who are serving these communities and
these groups of people who are ready to
hear what we have to say and to them
we're valuable because we're Hollywood
from the outside we're seen as Hollywood
who is doing something about an issue
that they care about or a story or a
point of view that they care about it's
up to us what we want to do but we may
need to emotionally detach ourselves
from the idea of what is fair and what's
not and sitting there and you know
trying to expect them to change for me
no it doesn't mean I just if they want
to work with us I'd love to talk to them
I'd love to work with them but I'm
talking about doing your work and that
being the determining factor is what's
fair and what's not fair and how that
should affect whether or not you do a
movie or tell this story or if I have to
conform in order to get into in you know
in okay fine but I want to do art and I
want to tell stories and I want to make
movies and I want people to enjoy those
films so if this group is not giving me
the opportunity to do that or doesn't
just see that I'm a value to them at
this particular stage of my career then
I'm gonna go to the people who do did
you see the movie quiz show from 1994 a
long time ago yeah it kind of reminds me
of that I mean it's a weird analogy but
you know it's based on you know this
John Turturro's character who's just
excellent in the film and he's like the
scrappy guy from New York and he knows
all the answers to these quiz show
questions and every night or or so these
Amer
and families are glued to their
television but after a while they want
to replace him yeah and so Michael asked
all Vargas like the I mean it's just so
great but it's a great analogy of then
they put the Ralph Fiennes this like
golden boy mm-hmm and you know very
bright guy but there's something about
him that they feel the American families
are gonna want to root for this guy we
got it we got it and so the movie is
Turturro and forgive me for not knowing
the character's name but fighting to
keep getting back on that show
it can't and he really wants it and the
more they tell him no he just goes crazy
and then basically they say he's crazy
because he wants it so badly right where
the Ralph Fiennes is just like this
gentleman and and he makes the cover of
time and so anyway it's just it's sort
of this interesting look that of like
fairness you know and and it turns out
in the end I don't know I don't want to
give it away but if you watch it you see
that even when he does wrong he still
applauded because he's seen as this hero
and and he's just painted as that yeah
you know and so it's a weird analogy and
I can't really put my finger on what I'm
destroying the illusion okay that I
guess that's it thank you okay but I
mean it essentially we're in a however
you want to look at it we're in a time
where an election two years ago blew a
hole in reality and there is an opening
to look on the outside for the first
time and all of this new information is
coming in and we as filmmakers need to
look at the scope of information and
assess its credibility and try to figure
out to make sense of what we're seeing
and hearing human trafficking was not on
my radar at all as far as for an a
social issue of a project that I was
going to do something about I've seen
documentaries on it I've seen one or two
films that have covered it but it was
through that disruption of unpredictable
things that came with all of this other
information and a journey of learning to
understand why we got here where we are
what's actually going on in the world
not the ones that's presented to us so
you have to you have a new reality
that's kind of emerging for many people
new information that's coming in - you
could call it political really not but
social cultural worldwide global event
which we have time if we want to observe
and look at through video through
articles through people on Twitter
talking about these issues debating them
in a public forum conversations that
haven't you know it's like it's all out
there it's a whole other worlds a new
frontier you can embrace it or you can
retreat to the old way and what I'm
saying is it's not about you have to
abandon your principles or anything like
that you become stronger and your
resolve to find that there is so much
more to this world out there than what
we've been presented with that we can do
such great things it gives me such great
hope for Humanity in the bigger and
broader sense of the long term when we
talk about child care when we talk about
what human trafficking is what it does
its effects on children long-term what
child abuse has in its effects long-term
on children and we we get into this
space but it's not about taking a point
of view it's trying to learn through the
experience of that information that's
coming at you to make sense of it and
then once I discovered after multiple
things that were prevented presented in
front of me fact-based Court FBI first
count testimonials from people who had
endured a lot of this stuff there was no
turning back I had to I had to or wanted
to do something and that was where I was
putting my foot down and going in that
direction so I think it is it's if
you're if you're gonna look at yourself
as a person of importance whether you do
or not it really doesn't matter but if
you if you if you see your job as a
filmmaker as being a position of of
social you know shaping social telling
social you know stories stories about us
we can tell news stories we can tell a
lot of different stories we can tell
stories that haven't ever been told
before because today there is this
enormous wealth of information out there
and there's a lot of BS too but it's
your job if you want to see it as like
you know I want to I want to help or I
want to shape ideas or I want to bring
this voice out it's our responsibility
to find the truth in that and that's
about being a truthful filmmaker as
opposed to one that has just a certain
idea about how that we want the world as
in this group over here who have a
certain agenda want to do certain things
they have a total right to do it but if
I am forcing my point of view on them
and I'm basically throwing a temper
tantrum because I'm not getting what I
want then reality that's only gonna hurt
me
and on top of that all of the people who
you know are being affected by this
issue are then going to get further you
know it's going to be completely ignored
because now you're not doing anything
because these people over here won't
help you when you know the truth and you
have your own creativity and your own
ideas and you can look at this and go
man this is something that's really
important I need to find a way to get
out there and start telling this story
have you ever made a movie for more than
250,000 no ok and have people said
there's just no way you're gonna do this
then oh yeah I mean I talk to people all
the time who are experienced - you know
micro-budget to them is half a million
quarter of a million is kind of like
that's the lowest they'll go and they
just can't conceive of it I mean if I
priced out my movies for what you know
they they would cost under normal
circumstances and I would say yeah I did
a quarter of a million half half a
million every time but you know we just
we we planned smart and we shoot you
know the scenes that we need to shoot
and
work within our limitations and embrace
them so I mean I've had I can't tell you
like how many times I don't think I've
had a film shoot even with pickups go
past 16 days most of it I'm in our last
film we shot principal in I think it was
10 or 11 days and then did two two days
of pickups we just were a very efficient
group we didn't work over 14 hours that
I can recall if we did and we may have
been one day most of its 12 12 13 her
biggest fed you know you just you just
roll with it yeah I would love to I'd
love to have a quarter of a million
dollars yeah well you could probably now
when you read this script when you say
what's more important or what do you do
first this the script of the budget so
you can probably see red flags like oh
this is gonna really cost or this is
great it's gonna keep it down yeah and
then and then that's a conversation with
the writer you have to talk to him and
say hey you know do we want to are you
open to the idea of changing this given
the given the resources we have
financially because you know we kind of
did an analysis general over and out and
Alison's gonna take this many number of
days to shoot so it's got fixed costs in
there you know daily rates for everybody
putting people up then we've got you
know whatever other things we have to do
how many actors we have to bring in that
kind of thing and and and you should
fight for a compromise but it's one that
is a shared vision as opposed to you're
right and they're wrong so but when I
read scripts today I'm definitely
looking at that and I'm like just seeing
it add up and I'm like okay locations
days you know there's ways you can do
some bringing consolidation and stuff
like that so it's not all like you know
when you're reading it in the full story
you just go oh there's only like four
locations here for a main location
that's easy makes it look like it moves
around a little bit more there that kind
of stuff and it's just I don't determine
my working on something in terms of what
budget I'm gonna do it at first right
but I'm gonna access it from a story
level and see what are the story points
that we need
yeah that you know maybe you don't have
a chase scene or if we have a chase
scene we shoot a certain way so like the
the chasing in our movie when you know
he goes to pick up the girl and they
shoot right okay you know I would have
loved to have done a whole bunch of
other stuff there but that's it and it
still worked it still worked but I had
to do you know certain angles and and
and you know just to sell the idea and
and in the in the editing room
you know Edgar knew this but when he was
shooting it and then they had story you
know they had done the shot list out
they figured that we can make it we can
sell this in a day we can do all of that
in one day you know actually a half a
day we shot that entire chase and run
down scene in a half a day and in it and
it worked so yeah you get there's
there's ways to get around it but you
just have to be creative is your goal
moving forward to go past a $250,000
budget or are you content staying here
and knowing that I'm gonna tell stories
that I want to tell we're gonna find
financing our way and not be beholden to
more money more problems yeah I mean
it's really like if there's something
that comes along that I'm really
passionate about and you know I see that
we can do it for X and I'm like okay are
we do we want to do this do we do we
want to do it without a script
supervisor in the first ad
I mean Edgar does that you know and
while he's directing oh so yeah I mean
that's that's that's the hard part but
in reality it's not about like no we've
graduated this level and now I can't you
know I've never looked at it that way I
just roll up my sleeves I do wardrobe I
do props I'm doing look you know like
doing everything wherever there's a hand
that's needed right and it's not because
I love doing that but it's needed
otherwise I got to come up with that
cash for somebody else to do it
so in short yes I would like more money
because I'd like to give the time that
we would love to have where we could do
you know all of the things
we have to cut out in editing because we
didn't have enough time or we didn't get
the actor to be able to get to that that
you know we didn't have the time to get
level that we wanted and we had to we
only had a certain number of takes that
we could do for that shot because of the
limitations of the budget in time so
these are the things that you have to
plan out and know what you're doing in
order to execute that and still get a
good you know finished product but money
doesn't always solve that so if it's the
crux of the issue is money then I think
you're gonna fail if it's innovation and
knowing what your resources are and
where you need to put them you know what
scenes you need to focus on so as a
director if you're focused on getting
Academy Award winning moments every
single take and every single scene
you're gonna be in deep trouble because
because in reality you have certain
story points where you definitely need
to work with the actor and you
definitely need to build that up because
if the story at the point of where
you're at in the story is very important
because you're coming to the end of the
film where everybody is is writing now
in that dude you know they follow the
the first and second act now we're in
the homestretch and everything has to
pay off so you don't want to compromise
where you have to you know go oh my god
I spent all of my time up front here
front loaded in the story where I really
needed to be the most impactful is in
this area where I'm seeing the
revelations and all of the you know all
of the turns that are coming all the
structure that we talked about in the
screenwriting all of that has to hit so
you have to make choices because of the
limitations if you have more money you
can you can just expand on that gives
you more breathing room gives you other
personnel to come in to take the the
concentration of a director and just
focus it solely on the actors not having
to think about the schedules not having
to think about you know where we are in
the script the continuity that kind of
stuff it it's it's really remarkable I
mean I know it's when people see our
films and they go oh my god I can't
believe you guys did that with such a
small crew in so many few days and so
little money that didn't just happen
it was because it was planned and I gave
a lot of that credit to Edgar because
he's really great with that I mean out
of necessities had to do it but the only
reason why I want more money is so that
his entire focus could be working with
the actors getting him to the emotional
beats that he that he that he really is
like desiring because he knows he gets
excited by the potential of what he's
seeing come out and come through and
working with them and and it's a trust
and it's such a beautiful thing I mean
as a producer I I may never direct a
movie but I can always enjoy the trust
between an actor and a director working
together and I want to finance that
potential I want to make sure that that
money is put in the in the appropriate
places to get the maximum impact so that
when the audience sees it they're like
whoa they're blown away like that was a
great performance that was real that was
I I felt I was there that's what I'm
going for
so if it comes at like thirty thousand
or fifty or a hundred or two hundred or
whatever it is or millions more the same
the same result should should occur if
you do everything correctly if you fight
if you follow what your passions are you
do all those points that I talked about
I don't think you can fail you're gonna
learn a lot you may make mistakes but I
don't think you will fail I think you'll
stumble you'll stumble forward to the
finish line with a with a very good
product that can be enjoyed not only
through the journey of doing that
project but by the people who are going
to receive it and see it and take
something from it